welcome to skull and bones our game
takes place during the golden age of
piracy in a world inspired by the
beautiful yet dangerous indian ocean
you'll start your journey as an outcast
whose goal is to become the most
infamous pirate to sail these
treacherous waters
after surviving a shipwreck you begin
your adventure in saint anne one of the
pirate demons in our world dens are
centers of pirate activity where you can
craft new ships and equipment provision
for your expeditions at sea pick up
contracts and socialize with other
players
any pirate worth their salt will tell
you that preparation is key to success
get ready for any challenges that come
your way by checking that your cargo is
stocked with items like food and
ammunition
once you're set it's time to head out
and explore
as a rookie pirate you'll only have
access to a small dow
but as you progress you'll be able to
craft different ships each with their
own unique play style
at sea you'll need to pay close
attention to the condition of your ship
and the morale of your crew your crew
are a pack of vicious raiders and rovers
who will mutiny against you if not kept
well fed and happy
if your ship sinks you'll lose some
progress and respawn at the nearest
discovered den or outpost
the good news is that most of your cargo
will be recovered and you'll have the
opportunity to retrieve the rest from
the wreckage but you'd better be quick
as other players can also steal it
as a pirate captain your reputation is
everything and our game tracks this
through infamy the higher your infamy
the more opportunities you'll get one of
the many ways to grow your infamy is to
take up contracts these are deals that
you can make with other pirates in the
world contracts can have great rewards
if you're successful or costs if you
fail
you can also gain infamy by completing
other activities such as exploration
plundering treasure hunts investigations
dynamic events and much more you can
undertake these either solo or with
other players the world of skull and
bones is filled with riches and
resources that you'll be able to gather
as you explore
lagoons and rivers are teeming with
dangerous wildlife that you can hunt for
animal skins and meat
you'll also be able to harvest a variety
of raw materials such as ore and wood
that can be refined and used for
crafting
crafting is an essential activity for
you to progress as an infamous pirate
obtain blueprints and use your refined
resources to craft stronger ships
weapons and armors
in skull and bones ships serve many
different purposes cargo ships are
slower but useful if you need to
transport large volumes of loot
navigation ships sail faster but have
less cargo space and lower hull hp
firepower ships have more gun ports
allowing you to deal higher damage but
are more challenging to maneuver
similarly you can craft a wide array of
unique weapons and armors from greek
fires to giant ballistic to rocket
launchers and mourners
as well as different armor types which
have varying strengths and weaknesses
against incoming attacks
with your new fleet and growing arsenal
create a loadout based on your personal
play style to become a force of
destruction
out in the open ocean opportunities and
threats are abundant
use your spyglass to identify lucrative
trade routes or wealthy merchant ships
and assess your prey's cargo and
firepower
strategize a plan of attack based on
your opponent's defenses and take
advantage of their weak points to deal
more damage
sinking your foes from afar rewards you
with only a portion of their cargo as
some of it will be lost to the depths
getting in close to execute a boarding
maneuver will help maximize your gains
but beware you can turn from predator to
prey in a heartbeat if you attract the
unwanted attention of privateers the
merciless pirate hunters that patrol the
seas
if you enjoy the thrill of the hunt you
can also seek out other players and
reign terror on them
such pvp battles are high stakes
activities that can be rewarding if you
emerge victorious
from your spoils of battle personalize
your individual look with outfits that
command respect
[Music]
you can also select from a multitude of
ship customization options to instill
fear in your enemies
with the wind in your sails journey to
the furthest reaches of the indian ocean
from the coast of africa to the east
indies
encounter extreme weather events like
violent storms and monstrous roadways
keep your eyes peeled for outposts which
are safe spots where you'll be able to
dock your ship for a short rest from the
perilous seas here you can trade with
traveling merchants and clandestine
smugglers selling rare and illegal goods
uncover buried bounties at outposts as
you decipher treasure maps obtained
through your voyages although all the
content and skull and bones can be done
solo you might enjoy ruling the seas
with your friends while sailing you can
also easily invite other pirates you
encounter to group up synergize your
different playstyles ships and weapons
to defeat deadlier enemies
as you grow stronger take on more
difficult challenges such as attacking
forts and plundering settlements and if
you're bold enough engage in dynamic
events like taking down heavily laden
merchant ships and their fleet of
warship escorts
now it's up to you to write your own
story remember there is no one path to
follow no one way to play
the world of skull and bones is yours to
discover
you